all right now I'm going to as promised
show you a third solution and I said
right at the beginning that this
solution is weird you're going to say
whoa this is so strange and long like
it's not an efficient process it's
actually quite time consuming however
what is attractive about it is that uh
it doesn't require similar triangles it
doesn't require
um any coordinate geometry at all in
fact all it really requires is a bit of
construction and a bit of counting which
you might think like how do you do this
problem just by counting like there's
fractions involved and all that kind of
thing well we'll reveal that in a moment
just before I show you the kind of path
that I'm going to take through the
question I just want to acknowledge
Andrew keep it who showed me this
solution I thought oh that's so clever
it's a really creative way of looking at
this problem the way that I would um
compare it to even though it's
inefficient so you might say why bother
learning it right what I would compare
it to is you know I I actually like bike
riding I enjoy bike riding so much that
last year I broke my collarbone coming
off my bike
um so I'm still bike riding because I
enjoy it now one of the things I like
when I'm bike riding is in my local area
working out a really interesting path to
get from A to B
um you know it's like okay I want to get
to that
um you know playground over there
because then my kids can have a good
time there and they can relax and then
we will come back home right so I want
to work out what is a clever way to get
from my house to that playground and
there are going to be like hundreds of
different parts that I can take some of
them
um are going to allow me to avoid you
know nasty looking heels which is handy
because I'm riding with my kids other
ways my a bit more Scenic maybe they're
a bit more shady and that kind of thing
or maybe they might take me through some
beautiful Bushland that's very
attractive it might be the long path but
it's just nice to go through a spot like
that because I live in an area with a
lot of Nature and what have you or it
sounds like a joke right but it's not
it's at the right or the wrong time uh
in Australia if you are riding your bike
around spring there's a lot of baby
birds that are being protected by their
parents and their nests and so the birds
particularly magpies are the funny ones
they're the black and white birds if
you're overseas and you've never heard
of these before they can be quite
aggressive and so what they will do is
they will swoop at you as you're riding
by and they'll actually like some of
them are pretty aggressive and they'll
they can like draw blood with their
talents and and hurt you quite badly and
even if they don't hurt you it's still
kind of creepy especially for the kids
right so I guess I'm highlighting this
to say maybe what I want to do is get
away from my home to the playground that
will avoid all all of the The Magpie
nests right because I actually can work
out where they are and there are even
some warning signs right so therefore
what I'm going to employ is all of my
logic and all my ability to read a map
and my experience of the area to try and
map out a nice way from A to B now
that's often going to be a longer way or
a more Scenic path it's not going to be
the most efficient if you want to take
the most efficient path you just get in
a car and you drive right that's going
to be the fastest for sure but sometimes
you want to go somewhere using your bike
rather than taking a car so what I'm
going to show you now is a solution that
well if you can drive and you know how
to drive then obviously you would do
that but there's a different kind of
attractiveness to taking a bike path to
do that and that's what is the method
that I'm going to show you it's kind of
a bit of a biking way of doing it so let
me take this diagram this is going to be
our starting point and I'm going to pop
it here
let's Chuck it on the left hand side and
I'm going to call this method three just
so that I I don't spoil it entirely I'm
going to call method three counting
because that is actually what we're
going to be doing and it's kind of fancy
cutting as you're going to see all right
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm just going to get rid of all this
information here and one of the
attractive things by the way about this
solution that I'm about to show you is
it doesn't even really require the
measurements that I've got here at least
not to do any calculations with them or
maybe a few small calculations but not
the kind of calculations you've just
been seeing right so I think by now we
know this problem well enough you know
that this a b is a half BC is also a
half this is three quarters this is one
quarter this is one okay so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start with
this diagram actually what I might do is
I might wrong wrong tool let me just
duplicate it over here because I'm going
to need to do this a couple of different
times and what I want you to notice is
all of the previous methods that we use
relied on the fact that we've got angles
here and we can manipulate those right
what I'm going to do here is rather than
look at the fact that there are
triangles I can say look there's a big
Square this blue shape in the middle has
been punched out you can see from these
other two weird shapes on the side a b g
e f so it's a pentagon a weird Pentagon
and then I've also got b c d e h another
weird Pentagon over there right so what
I'm going to do is think about the whole
Square which I know has an area of one
and then I want to think about these two
weird pentagons again I guess you could
think about it as I'm still using
subtraction but it's a different I'm
subtracting different shapes so I'm
thinking about different composite
figures here so if I were trying to
think about let's uh let's get rid of
this Focus here if I were trying to
think about this weird Pentagon over
here on the left so what do we call that
a b uh g e f so if I were to try and
work out what's Happening Here Right
one of the ways that I could approach
this and this you're going to say like
this is so strange and counter-intuitive
is I can just think of it in terms of
the lines that make it up in this case
as we're looking at in the corner
geometry version a e and then BF those
two lines Define for me what kind of
shape I get out of this weirdo looking
Pentagon right so I'm actually going to
temporarily get rid of all the rest of
this information I'm just going to focus
on this green shape here
excuse me all right now uh oh what I
wanted that's not meant to be a
highlighter I'm going to change that
how do I fiddle with that I want it to
be a pencil oh well I'll just use this
one okay what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use the um the the lines that
I've got here
um a e and b f to uh create a pattern
across this square that allows me to
evaluate the green pentagon
still feels weird calling it a pentagon
but it's got five vertices and five
edges I'm going to evaluate the area of
this weirdo looking Pentagon that I
don't even have an area formula for a
pentagon but I don't need one if I can
work out what proportion the green
pentagon is of the total square how am I
going to do that well watch this it's
weird but just stay with me okay I'm
going to divide up this this shape this
big Square using lines that are parallel
to the uh the AE over here so I need one
more it's going to look like
uh let's see here I guess I'm oh that's
that's terrible
um that's actually going to go all the
way down there there we go all right so
what I've got is I've got four lines
here that are all parallel to a well
three lines three additional lines that
are all parallel to AE and then I'm
going to rehearse that um that process
to get lines that are parallel to b f so
let's see here that's looking at that
slant it's going to go across like so
this one's going to go across like so
um I missed that spot let's try that
again that's better if I go up for the
bottom it does that and I need one over
this side for completeness okay
so what have I got here all right this
immediately looks weird and strange and
confusing right but I hope what you can
see here is I've divided the square
um a c d f into a bunch of parallelogram
style units okay or you could think of
them as tiles because there's a
Tessellation going on here okay now uh
because of the way it's tiled and the
fact that the square goes right over the
top of them some of the tiles I guess
they're parallelogram tiles some of the
tiles are complete and other ones are
cut off by the edges of the square right
so my question is how many
tiles are either are made up of the
entire Square
and then how many tiles does the uh the
green Pentagon take up in proportion to
the whole Square okay so stay with me
and you might be able to see this logic
sort of unfold right what I've got here
is
um and by the way I'm gonna I'm gonna
take this and for reasons it's gonna
become clear in a second I'm going to
um grab another one and put it over here
for comparison I think I've still got
space yep so what I'm going to do in the
first this is is I'm gonna work out I
don't even need G there in the middle in
fact I don't need any of this around the
edges so let's no no coordinate or or
labeling of um side arguments like
deduction required I just can just can
count which is what's attractive about
this process let's look at the left hand
side and work out how many complete
tiles it takes to fill up this Square
okay so the first complete tile I see is
here one okay so let me highlight that
as kind of our unit right I've got this
shape here
this is one complete tile how many of
these make up the square well there are
some that are easier to see and some
that are harder so I see a second one
here third fourth fifth and then sixth
and if I'm not mistaken all the rest of
them are cut off by the edges right but
if you look closely you'll see
for example if you divide this first one
up in half right you can see you've got
a half up here and it corresponds to
this half down here it's a tiling right
so a Tessellation it just goes off
forever right so what I can say is I'm
up to six at the moment so this is half
of the seventh one and this is the other
half of the seventh tile the seventh
parallelogram right and I can keep this
process going here's the top of one and
the bottom of that same one
here's a ninth one here is a tenth one
and then what have I got here on the
other sides right well there's a couple
different ways to think about this if
you have a look
see see this um this triangle over here
it's it's a slice of a tile that
actually comes from the other side of
the square can you see if I actually
take this here if I draw it like so I
might be able to just pick it up let's
see if I'm accurate enough
can I grab it yes okay if I put it over
here can you see what I've created over
here this is one whole tile just like
tile number one right so this
um if I combine them you can see they
they make one complete hole so really
what I've got is what am I up to I'm up
to um wrong color I'm up to 10 at the
moment so this is the a part of the 11th
one and this is the other part they're
obviously not halves 11b is much bigger
than 11a and I can use the same logic to
say hey this is one part of the 12th and
here's the other part 12 B okay so
you've seen my logic here I've now
accounted for every tile on this Square
the whole area is one but 12 tiles equal
tiles make up this this entire Square so
each one of these tiles without any sort
of formula or calculation each one must
have an area of 1 12 right so green
tiles here
oops grain tiles
are equal to 1 over 12 of a square
centimeter I guess in this case right
now what I need to know is how many
tiles make up this weirdo Pentagon right
and we can do the same process I'm just
going to be counting right same deal I'm
going to do the whole tiles first and
then I'm going to do the part tiles
after right so this is the only whole
title that I can see in the green
pentagon
I can see this is the first half of one
tile the second tail and then I'm
looking at this one there's no
corresponding bottom part to that so
I'll leave that for a moment but then
you can see these two parts here I'm
using the same argument that I did over
here for this 11th one you can imagine
sort of rotating this around and it
would end up creating a whole let me
just do it very messily here it will
create a whole tile there wow that's
really badly drawn but you get the idea
okay
uh actually that's bothering me so much
I'll try and
um sort of do a bit more accurately so
there you go so that that should go the
same amount of that but you get the idea
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say um what am I talking about
this is this is the first tile this
together makes the second tile here
comes a third tile here's 3A I'll call
this 3B
and then this one here it's just kind of
a loose end so it's half of I guess the
fourth tile
fourth tile so what have I got here well
my Pentagon my green Pentagon green
Pentagon how many tiles is it it's three
and a half of those tiles right I've got
one whole one there two whole ones three
whole ones and then there's three and a
half right so it's three and a half
times 1 12 right so three and a half
over 12 I can say well that's uh
multiply top and bottom by two so that's
going to be 7 over 24 and by the way
that 24 should look familiar I'm going
to come back to it momentarily
so what I just done I've worked out this
left hand part here which I can subtract
later without any formulas without any
similar triangles or coordinates all
I've done is I've created this tiling
and then counted the appropriate number
of tiles and that's given me this area
over here
now uh just I mean you're starting to
get secret right I'm going to rehearse
this logic but I'm going to do it for
the right hand side so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say all right I don't
need this or any of this anymore
all I need to work out is what's going
on with this side of the
um diagram here this Pentagon that I'm
creating very messily on this side ta-da
so um in much the same way as I did
before I'm going to let's move this out
of the way so I have space I'm here I'll
just move this down so I can draw on it
uh before I work out what this purple
pentagon is what I have to do is work
out the tiling right so I should have
gotten rid of those shouldn't I so I'm
going to do the tiling using this side
over here and I'm going to do the same
process of parallel lines right so I'm
going to go looks to me like I'm going
to need a parallel line here
parallel line here
it's a bit messy because the idea
there's one more over there and I'll
need one more matching here
and then for this other one the
gradient's four over three which is
slightly awkward but that's okay we can
make it work uh let's try and go well
I'm just going to do a straight line
there that's cheating slightly but you
get the idea so this straight line
where's it going to go so it's going to
collide about there this I need more
space to wait this one out so this
straight line should finish
here
straight line so I can see it's going to
collide about there let's go do in the
other direction so a straight line
should go to there
straight line should go to
there okay fantastic all right so have I
got this right I think I'm pretty
satisfied with that there are more tiles
that you can see here but I'm going to
go through the same process and do some
counting right so one that's my first
com my first complete tile there right
there
it's going to use this as my what I'm
going to count for the rest of it
there's a whole one there three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve and you're gonna be careful right
this one here looks like it's a 13th but
it's been cut off on the edge there all
right let's take great care and work out
how many other tiles I can complete
using the pieces right so I went to 12
at the moment so I'm gonna go 13 a and
13 B just here 14.
15 up here
I'm up to 16. now I've got these awkward
Edge pieces to deal with so when I look
carefully it looks like what I'm going
to get is and I'll go I actually can
I'll use the left and right like I did
earlier because I think that makes the
pattern a bit more obvious here is the
17th one so from the left I then go over
to the right so this is 17b
this one will be number 18 and then
you've got this tiny sliver over here
which is also 18. over here I'm up to
19. and then this big one here
corresponds and then this would be 20
and our last one so this would be 20 b
right so now I know 20 complete tiles or
sorry 20 tiles to complete the square so
therefore each of the tiles is 1 over
20. so I'll write that down
purple tail
equals 1 over 20 and now I need to know
how many tiles in this purple Pentagon
so actually
um yeah I should have actually
um how did I do that before I did the I
know I did the I forgot to delete the or
copy it before I did the counting but
anyway that's all right actually you
know what maybe we can
uh let me see if I can be a little
cheeky and use
um this over here
duplicates this kind of a slightly
different way all right so I'm going to
do some circling here all right so I've
got
one two three four five so these are
complete you can see uh so I'm up to
five complete
then I can match up
um these A's up here with that b so
that's another complete one
this is two that I've made out of there
so they're tops and bottoms there's no
more there's not a top and bottom to go
with this one so I'm just going to leave
that so I'm going to go to up down ones
then you can see let's have a look here
in the same way that you can see this
17b what it wants to pair with is one of
these looking shapes you can see down
the bottom here right so I'm going to
pair up this 17b with this 20b and then
you can see in the same way I've got
this these two pairing together this is
a really big one and this is like a tiny
sliver so I've got another two
that are these um Left Right versions
and then what that leaves me with is the
theme that I've labeled here is 16b so
it's half right so therefore it's going
to be a half
a half tile right so what have I got
here five plus two plus two plus a half
that's going to be nine and a half so
therefore I can say
purple pentagon
is equal to nine and a half
make sure I get that right
um times 1 over 20. doing a similar
process before so I can get rid of the
halves that's going to be 19 over 40 and
that 40 should also look familiar let's
go all the way back
to the top up here can you see
um this I sort of flagged this before
this over 24 and this over 40 came from
doing these denominators right when we
were working out the area well we
haven't gone anywhere near uh and an
area formula for a triangle but the same
24 and the same 40 have emerged because
essentially what you're working out is
how many of those tiles will fit into
the hole right so now I can say all
right I'm ready to go
um I'm just gonna I don't say blue area
equals the whole square is one what I'm
going to then take away is the green and
the purple pentagons in this case so
that's going to be 7 over 24.
take away 19 over 40 and I'm just going
to quickly highlight the fact that if I
go
back to the original solution that I
showed you back up here
what I love is how parallel but how
slightly different they are right
because you've still got 24 when you're
dealing with that left hand side of the
diagram because the proportions you
still got 40ths when you're dealing with
the right hand side because of the
proportions you get there from the
original diagram like so but because
you're starting with a different shape
this is a square versus the triangle BDF
therefore you're working out different
things however delightfully go ahead and
check that out in a in a calculator if
you really want to be satisfied that is
still going to equal 7 over 30 and those
were square centimeters as we determined
before so I know that was a weird
solution but it is delightful for me
that we can use like take a whole
different perspective on the problem and
still as so often happens in mathematics
arrive at this one solution so we can
have great confidence that whichever
path we took we know that we were
accurate
so I hope you enjoyed those methods like
I said um I would if I if I got
presented with this problem well this
problem I would definitely instinctively
always go for this first method of
solution
um I guess the more sophisticated
knowledge you can take advantage of and
similar triangles they they actually
mask a lot of um great geometric
reasoning just in
um the properties that we have learned
about every single shape like similar
triangles or like properties of a
quadrilateral and that kind of thing
they enable your calculations to be more
straightforward and so that's why you
can see here I had to pull out some
equations here I had to know how to sell
simultaneously which I didn't really
have to do at all here in the first
solution so it uses I would say kind of
the most sophisticated tools which is
why you don't have to work very hard
with them the equations are all pretty
straightforward and as you go further
back you know as I go to more and more
quote unquote basic techniques and I
said oh cool no formulas but whoa that
was laborious right especially this last
one even just working out how many tiles
they were was a weird kind a problem to
solve it is still elegant in its own way
because it doesn't require any Advanced
Techniques just some patience and a bit
of construction